actually say they say 40 men report to
not be having but what they don't report
is they're not not having sex because of
women it's because they don't feel
confident in themselves so actually I
actually saw the report it was saying
things like I've had a lot of things
sorry they reported things like I've had
a lot of chances but because I didn't
feel like I was going to do it right and
they said the reason that they feel this
insecurity is because of social media
and you know in Social mediences really
because if I have a small Willy then I'm
not taking it out but I feel like if
so you're saying these guys have women
that are down they're ready to sleep
with them okay okay wait so these 40
Birds let me just that yeah I just want
to make sure that's what they say okay
you're telling me these 40 of men have
guys or girls girls not guys girls ready
to sleep with them and they're just
saying you know what I don't feel good
about myself I'm not going to no I'm not
saying so many women want to have sex
with them I'm saying these same men
reported that they've been in situations
where they could have had sex but they
didn't feel confident in themselves to
say you know what I can do this right
but and you know whether insecurity
actually comes from other men men go out
talking about their game okay oh I've
got this you know I can pull any girl it
makes other men actually feel insecure
in themselves when actually in reality
women will have sex with any man as long
as you fulfill her needs it doesn't have
to be sexual it can be emotional need it
can speak for yourself
[Music]
I'm a tall girl I'm a tall girl I'm six
foot right it doesn't matter how good a
five five guy makes me feel right
[Applause]
if I was shorter it'd be different but
I'm tall like but that's cute you could
just like
okay you guys can do that that's fine
I'm not but the thing is aren't you
single are you single
yeah yeah then what what input do you
have on any of those what do you think
is it one of your big rows so like women
have standards that are too high and
they're not being realized blah blah
blah blah now you're looking for a guy
that's what six one at least
five five Destiny
that's what I said that's like 50
standard deviations
[Laughter]
I said no guy that is five five sorry
you do this when people are talking
we're supposed to speak about for
everybody but then when every time you
give an example you go to like the
eighth standard deviation away from the
norm yeah how many guys are five five
it's like less than 100 okay yeah look
at five seven you know
you think it benefited man what do you
think Destiny I think there's pros and
cons to everybody that's going to be the
same for everything it's nice for women
because women can have more sex without
necessarily getting pregnant and having
kids women have a little bit more
Independence so they can explore
sexually without being tied down to one
man that they have to marry for men
there is more availability of sex I know
there was that 140 number but I think
that was uh quoted I want to say in 2021
it was like when the pandemic was crazy
and everything I think that fell I don't
know what it fell to
um but I mean like yeah like sex is more
available now than it was in the past
for most people which is but there's
pros and cons right there's going to be
more competition for sex there's going
to be more competition for relationships
back 30 40 50 years ago all a man had to
do was work a job and he was basically
like guaranteed a wife because women
couldn't work
um yeah I think it's important to
recognize or pros and cons to everything
can I point something out a lot of the
time you guys talk about this 80 20
ratio but like women are all gunning for
the same man and like
those studies that you
um reference they're all based on dating
apps like Okay Cupid and Tinder and I
just want to say like dating in the real
world is far different to our choices on
Tinder like there could be a perfect man
on a hinge and I will see lives in
dagenham
that is true that is true I'm crazy I'm
crazy on them as because everyone but if
someone is in front of me that that I
get along with and I can learn to love
then all this nonsense of marketization
and all this
writing yourself it's absolutely
the point is we swipe right on dating
apps what five percent of the time what
do you mean yeah but that's because wait
wait wait let me so so even if we we
triple it quadruple it that's still only
20 we could double it make it 40 it's
five to one men to women on these apps
of course women are going to be highly
selected
highly and women are highly selective in
real life as well absolutely not not as
much as men as much as men
two questions do you do you think Matt
who's picky or men or women when it
comes to what when it comes to four
relationships for relationships I think
men tend to get keep relationships more
for sex women you think men are equally
picky when it comes to relationships or
sex let's say relationships well it's
important because you guys mix them up a
lot
I'm not mixing them okay for
relationships I think men can gatekeep
more than women do no I'm asking if you
think they're equally picky with the
women that they want to be in
relationships with as women are to men
um
are men as women so so for you if you
were gonna if you were gonna I mean
you're already married right and I'm I'm
looking for a husband and you're looking
for a wife who's pickier typically by
and large and I'm not not like I'm just
using I think it's I think it's I think
it's roughly equal really that's so
interesting it's interesting but the
reason why is because you guys get all
your information from dating from dating
apps where the numbers are super skewed
but if you go into any school all the
boys are dating all the girls if you go
into any workplace
if you go into any workplace all the
boys are dating all the girls when their
environments where men and women are
together look at the YouTube
that's how it works but the problem is
you guys are only looking at like well
look at Tinder where it's five men to
one woman I don't actually agree on
college campuses it's similar I would
say it's similar on college campuses
there's like a select group of men that
tend to do very well no hold on wait no
no wait you okay what you just said is a
highlight of why I think you're not
either engaging no no wait because you
said men do very well
can I just I said a select group of men
you said a selective so for example like
athletes no one athlete is not dating
five women a select group of men they
might have sex but that's why I say it's
important to distinguish sex between
relationships an elite group of men can
[__] a lot of women sure only group of
women
yeah sure can I ask you a question like
okay I'm not I'm not saying in terms of
relationships I'm saying in the initial
encounters where men come together with
women we're not even talking about
relationships now we're just that
initial moment when they meet who's
usually going to be more pickier who's
who's going to be more willing to like
settle with whatever comes their way
wherever you know they catch that night
or whenever they meet in in their real
life yeah when you've got to be more
who's going to be more picky
no I think no no no listen listen listen
before the sex or the relationship has
come yeah you first have to meet that
person and you subconsciously you know
in your mind not even subconsciously you
know in your mind if I would sleep with
that person or I would give them a
chance as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible